rcf le modem a dévoilé il ya quelques
jours la liste des chefs de file pour
les élections régionales des chefs de
file et pas forcément tous tête de liste
car le parti conduit par françois bayrou
compte bien nouer des alliances
peut-être d'ici la rentrée françois
bayrou qui était justement hier à vaulx
en velin pour rencontrer le modem du
rhône et évoquer les élections
régionales qui concerne la région
rhône-alpes bien sûr et l'auvergne on en
parle ce matin avec françois xavier
pénicaud bonjour bonjour les biens de m
vous êtes donc le président du modem rom
rhône où vous étiez hier à aux côtés de
françois bayrou jugé tout début donc
rencontré tous les militants
on a désigné des chefs de file et pas
des têtes de liste la distinction est
importante
bien sûr à deux égards le premier et on
va faire un peu de pédagogie sur cette
échéance c'est qu'il n'y a pas de tête
de liste régionale dans un scrutin il y
à des têtes de listes départementales et
vous avez un chef de file régional qui
votre candidat à la présidence de la
région ensuite en l'occurrence lorsque
nous parlons de chef de file
c'est les personnes qui ont vocation à
conduire le projet et les équipes du
mouvement dans cette échéance mais si le
mouvement démocrate parle de dépassement
des clivages c'est pas pour en régaler
un autour de lui en étant sectaire et en
refusant tout dialogue avec toute
formation donc bien entendu je pense que
surtout dans les temps un petit peu de
difficulté à la fois économique et de
fébrilité républicaine que l'on connaît
il est relativement important d'essayer
de construire des rassemblements qui
dépasse une étiquette et puis on y sera
un enjeu régional de territoire et que
ce soit en rhône alpes auvergne ou dans
d'autres régions il est bien logique que
sur des questions de cet ordre là ce
n'est pas les questions d'éthique est
qu'ils sont un intérêt mais quels sont
les projets régionaux et du coup qu'ils
sont ceux qui se fédèrent autour de ce
projet cohérent alors pour la région
rhône alpes auvergne le chef de file
c'est patrick mignola tout à fait quel
est son rôle alors si si finalement il
n'est pas candidat forcément la
présidence de la super grande région
alors en l'occurrence en ce qui concerne
auvergne rhône-alpes on a beaucoup vous
discutez et notamment hier avec françois
bayrou et le mutant du contexte dans
lequel on se situait du territoire dans
lequel on se situer et disons de déols
phrase alternative qui nous entoure
aujourd'hui patrick mignola a vocation à
être candidat à la présidence de la
région donc pas d'alliance avec une
liste clairement avec l'ump par exemple
ou avait calculé en ce qui concerne
l'ump nous on était près tout à fait
prêt à pouvoir travailler avec quelqu'un
comme michel barnier avec qui on avait
effectivement des convergences de vues
sur le projet régional nicolas sarkozy
dans sa dans une démarche très de
fermeture et achever le choix d'un
candidat qui symbolisent les clivages
les antagonismes et c'était des c'était
un refus de la part de nicolas sarkozy
et de l'ump d' envisager de construire
une majorité commune du moins une liste
de premier tour avec le mouvement
démocrate du moins à partir du moment où
on fait un choix qui et
programmatiquement contraire il n'y a
pas la possibilité de converger on est
là sur des oeufs sur des divergences bon
d'une part de valeur je vais pas revenir
parfois sur les instruments tu les
instrumentalisations pardonnez-moi de
certains événements divers à des fins
politiciennes qui sont excessivement
gênant mais on a des divergences
profondes aussi sur vos projets rejouer
avec l'en ok donc non aujourd'hui la
question de faire une liste commune avec
laurent wauquiez n'est pas sur la tonne
vous êtes en train de dire que c'est
l'ump qui veut pas du modem c'est pas le
modem qui peut pas s'allier avec l'ump
nous on a fait quand vous construisez un
projet
commun vous construisez communément il
n'y a pas eu de volonté bien que nous on
est con ai dit effectivement que nous
étions prêts à travailler avec une
personnalité comme michèle bernier parce
que ce qui est important c'est qu'elles
sont les rassemblements qu'on va pouvoir
construire pour cette région c'est
comment on va pouvoir faire s'allier des
personnes autour d'un projet cohérent
dans une démarche elle aussi cohérente
donc voilà l'ump a fait son choix de
rester de façon sectaire et dans une
démarche qui agite les antagonismes qui
agite les passions mais au sens négatif
du terme on a besoin d'une région
ouverte aux verts du rhône alpes qui
soit ouverte sur l'europe sur le monde
c'est une région c'est une région europe
c'est la septième rejoint d'europe c'est
une région dont l'économie elle même est
tourné vers l'extérieur elle doit être
en capacité non seulement de tirer
l'économie de la france mais même de
notre continent il faut avoir conscience
de cette responsabilité michel barnier
était capable de porter ça laurent
wauquiez n'eut pas alors pas d'alliance
avec l'ump qu'en est il de lui d
écouter chacun se détermine comme il le
souhaite nous on pense qu'il faut qu'il
y ait un projet qui ressemble à cette
région faisant des cadeaux de trois
lignes
nous sommes convaincus et les échanges
que nous avons avec le délit et les
prises de paroles programmatique qu'ils
ont eue laissent penser qu' il ya
largement effectivement la possibilité
d'avoir un projet commun avec eux
maintenant chacun se détermine comme il
le souhaite nous en tout cas notre porte
est tout à fait ouverte parce que ce
n'est pas une liste mouvement démocrate
que va conduire patrick mignola
d'ailleurs patrick mignola est un profil
beaucoup plus civil que mouvement
démocrate c'est un chef d'entreprise
c'est quelqu'un qui n'est pas dans les
clivages partisans qui n'est pas plus
modem qu' il est avant tout rhônalpins
et auvergnats est engagée sur son
territoire et on est absolument pas
fermé au contraire on cherche à
construire un rassemblement avec un
certain nombre de personnes de lui il y
en a peut-être certains qu'ils auront
avec laurent wauquiez mais un certain
nombre j'en suis sûr vous savez trop en
cohérence avec leur projet et pas qu'à
lui failli dans la société civile dans
des mouvements je suis sûr que quand
vous allez vous regarder dans des
mouvements comme des nous citoyens ou
même certains élus ump ou même certains
cette affaire sociales il y a des gens
qui vont nous retrouver sur ce projet
tout à fait pour finir à françois xavier
pénicaud quels sont les prochains les
prochaines séances le scrutin c'est ans
descendre vous me dit tout à l'heure on
va donc déterminer ensuite par
département comment ça va se passer
c'est patrick mignola qui va décider un
peu qui va ou qui fait quoi déjà avant
la question des personnes c'est qu'on va
poursuivre le travail programmatique on
a mis en place six commissions de
travail inter régional hier après un
travail disons asynchrone jusque là on
va avoir des commissions de travail
interdépartemental avec des responsables
de commissions qui sont en train d'être
mis en place et on va affiner le projet
ça c'est le premier bon c'est quand même
l'essentiel
vous pouvez avoir des têtes mais si vous
avez rien dedans ça ne marche pas et en
ce qui concerne des têtes de listes
effectivement on va essayer dans les
prochaines semaines est au plus tard
d'ici l'été de présenter de construire
ce rassemblement est de présenter des
têtes de listes départementales voilà
donc on connaîtra un peu plus
précisément et le programme et les gens
qui conduiront d'ici la fin de l'été à
la rentrée merci françois xavier
pénicaud vous êtes donc le président du
modem du rhône et vous êtes venu ce
matin vous parlez donc de cette liste
qui sera conduite par patrick mignola
merci à vous nous vous en prie